hey does Donald Trump know that there
are female governors in the United
States this is so funny you might have
heard that Donald Trump had the nation's
governor's at the White House on Sunday
night for a dinner he had 46 governor's
there okay he greeted them by welcoming
them and their wives he said it twice in
fact of course there are female
governors he also said it was great to
meet people's daughters not sons and
daughters just very strange no one has
been able to figure out why he singled
out daughters and of course a number of
different governors were asked what was
up with that welcoming governors and
their wives and only saying meeting
people's daughters Oregon governor Kate
brown said quote it was weird we have a
number of female US governor susana
Martinez from New Mexico Mary Fallon
from Oklahoma
Kate Brown from Oregon as I mentioned
Gina Raimondo from Rhode Island Donald
Trump also weirdly said to the
governor's it's such an easy job you
have which was really weird he was
supposed to just go up there and welcome
everybody to dinner and it turned into
like most things with Trump an
opportunity to slam things related to
immigration or Obamacare or whatever
although this was just a social function
very bizarre situation what's not with
this guy yeah I mean it not only
discounts the possibility that a
governor could be a woman it also
discounts the possibility that a
governor could be part of the LGBT
community yes because in a roomful of 50
people most of them are men in this case
just statistically it's possible that
some of them could be gay it turns out
that only one of these governors
this.get is bisexual in this case kate
brown yeah even though she's married to
a man but yeah very bizarre and uh you
got to be welcoming in in a situation
like that speaking of kate brown a
governor from oregon she's been signing
executive orders in oregon to try to
counteract some of donald trump's
proposals about undocumented immigrants
and Muslims she said she didn't really
have much interaction with Trump that
night not particularly surprising she
did although get her picture taken with
him and when someone announced who she
was and what state she was from in you
know Trump has no clue what's going on
Trump said Oregon's a great state a
really great state and I wonder if Trump
has any idea what some of these
governors are actually doing what the
hell is going on here just ever
the aspect of everything that Trump does
every event that Trump does has
something off-color or weird about it
it's still strange to me I mean this is
a reality TV star so to see him speak in
front of all these governors to see him
speak in front of Congress yeah
I'm not used to it yet now I'm used to
grab them by the [ __ ] and evaluating
women's physical appearance on a scale
of one to ten that's what I associate
Trump with you and using foreign steel
to build buildings in New York City of
course I mean who doesn't associate
Trump with that today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription into I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they started just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial com /t DPS